we've got triangles uh but these are
special triangles uh they're called hero
triangles you'll like that heronian
triangles
and these are particular types of hero
triangles a hero triangle is a triangle
that has integer sides whole number
sides and an integer area okay so it's
just something that mathematicians like
to play with uh you should think of
these a lot like perfect numbers and
things like that it's just something
that mathematicians like to have fun
with we've we've played with these for a
long time even now we're still coming up
with new things about them uh but these
are particularly special uh they're
superhero drivers these are our super
hero triangles absolutely i've now given
you permission to put click bait
thumbnails on this video get captain
america over here i can't believe it
superhero triangles so my first one it's
a right angle triangle so the idea is
they've got integer sides and so this
has sides 5
12
and 13 which is called a pythagorean
triangle as well pythagorean triple but
this is what i wanted to point out look
at the perimeter the perimeter is adding
up the three sides and so i reckon the
perimeter is thirty so twelve plus
thirteen plus five and the area if you
work out the area where it's half the
base times the height if you remember
the formula for an area of a triangle
which will be 30 as well so they've got
the same perimeter they've got the same
area that's what these five triangles
have in common so if i do my next one
you can see this one's a right angle
triangle as well perimeter is 24 area is
24. and let's have a look at these next
three and this one perimeter what is the
perimeter 36 and you won't be surprised
area is 36 as well these ones aren't
right angles are they these are so these
yeah these last three i'm drawing out
are not right angle triangles if you
look at the perimeter oh perimeter 42
area 42 everyone's favorite and the last
one this really long one then so the
perimeter is 60 area is 60 right they do
remind me of perfect numbers the way
that they kind of refer back to itself a
perfect number is when you look at the
factors of the number and it adds up to
itself and it reminds me of that so the
perimeter and the area are the same and
even though there are an infinity of
possible triangles we could have with
integer sides integer areas
these are the only five
that have the same perimeter and the
same area so there is five and five only
presumably you can
up size these same five that is that is
a good point but the problem with that
is if we talk say this triangle if we
double it
then we would double the perimeter and
the area gets multiplied by four
so when you double the perimeter area is
multiplied by four so even
including scaled up versions of
triangles
this is the five the only five we can
find so let me just give you some facts
about this these things go back
thousands of years it's just one of
those things mathematicians study so
these are facts about the hironian
triangles which means they have integer
size and integer area so they are named
after a mathematician uh from way back 2
000 years ago hero of alexandria they're
not that hard to find we saw that we can
do it with a pythagorean triangle
pythagorean triples that's a well-known
thing
and there are infinitely many of these
and they're quite easy to make i mean
the simplest is the the three four five
triangle perimeter 12 and the area half
the base times the height is 6. so you
can do this but any pythagorean triangle
would work as another example 17 15 8
would work as well so it's got an
integer perimeter which i think is 40
and the area is a integer as well 60.
that's going to be guaranteed to be an
integer so they're heroes but not
superheroes that's right guaranteed
every pythagorean triangle is going to
have this property because you're going
to have an integer perimeter and yes
you're guaranteed to have integer area
as well and what i mean is you're
guaranteed because it's half the base
times the height
it means you are guaranteed that one of
these sides is an even number so out of
all those infinite
pythagorean triangles only two of them
have this property where the area is the
same as the perimeter and then the other
three are not
right angle triangle so what else could
we have uh so i can tell you straight
away if you wanted an equilateral
triangle like this with sides all the
same length whatever that is i'm afraid
that's never going to have an integer
area so you can't do it with equilateral
triangles they don't exist what else
could we do what about an isosceles
triangle yes we can do that i'll show
you an example a 5 a 5 and a 6.
perimeter is 16 and the area is going to
be 12. so we've got
integer perimeter integer area it's a
bit of a cheat though i don't have you
noticed it was a bit of a cheat because
if i drop a vertical line here
what it is is actually two
right angle triangles stuck together
it's actually a five four three
right angle triangle stuck together so
i'm afraid yes you can do isosceles
triangles although they are a bit of a
cheat so can we make triangles
that are not
a bit of a cheat okay so we'll go a bit
more general now here's another triangle
it's going to be a 15 a 20 and a 25 so
oh what's it going to be perimeter is 60
area is 150. so this works this is one
of our hero triangles but i've cheated
again because you can drop a vertical
line you can split it into two right
angle triangles so the question is are
they are they all cheats are there any
triangles that aren't just made out of
pythagorean right angle triangles
so you can do triangles that aren't
cheats here is a 5 29 and 30. so here's
a triangle with a perimeter of 64 and an
area of 72 and that cannot be broken up
into two right angle triangles that are
pythagorean if you drop a vertical line
here well we know what it's half the
base times the height we're trying to
work out the height now so area
is half
base times height
i'm trying to work out the height
so the height is going to be well twice
the area
divided by my base
which is
144 divided by 30
but it's not an integer which means it's
not going to be a right angle triangle
with integer psi when you get these
these are called the indecomposable ones
they're ones that you can't break up you
can break them up into right angle
triangles and they're going to be
rational sided right angle triangles but
not always integer ones so these are
like indecomposable so why are these
called hero triangles named after hero
of alexandria who mathematician 2 000
years ago worked in the library of
alexandria like this big famous thing
and there is a formula for the area of a
triangle that is credited to hero of
alexandria which i wasn't taught at
school and i wish i was i was taught
area of a triangle is half the base
times the height and i've always used
that and sometimes the height is
difficult to work out and you have to
use a bit of pythagoras theorem work out
the height and then you can do half the
base times the height
well here's a formula where we don't
need to know the height of your triangle
the area of this triangle is going to
use a b and c
lovely now the perimeter is a plus b
plus c i'm going to use something called
a semi-perimeter which you might be able
to guess is half the perimeter and we're
going to use that in the formula for
area the area of this triangle
is the semi-perimeter
multiplied by semi-perimeter minus a
side a
multiplied by semi-perimeter minus
b
multiplied by semi-perimeter minus c
and the final thing is all square rooted
so i wonder if i wanted to work out my
previous example which was a 5 29 30 and
i don't want to work out the height then
i can use this formula it's going to be
half the perimeter multiplied by 32
minus let's do side a's five so that's
going to be 27 multiplied by 32 minus 29
which is an easy three minus 32 minus 30
which is just a two
that is going to be square rooted so you
can
we'll work it out okay multiply this out
it is 72. not bad it's a lovely formula
isn't it you get the formula by
pythagoras's theorem use pythagoras
theorem over and over again rewrite it
in terms of a b and c
but it turns out really neat you get
this lovely neat formula without having
to work out the height of the triangle
but
we were interested in triangles that
have the same perimeter and the same
area the superheroes these are the
superheroes we've got a formula for area
so let's do it right we've got area is
this
we want it to be the same as 2s that's
the perimeter is equal to area which is
the square root thing all right oh well
let's just tidy it up you know square
both sides
4s squared
it's this stuff
and then we can divide
by s we've got s on both sides so we get
4s
equals
s minus a s minus b
s minus c
little formula and i might not go
through the whole thing but you can do
this i recommend if you want to solve
this now and find those triangles
let's call these three terms x y and z
the left-hand side four times s will
become four times x plus y plus z so oh
let's say x is less than y less than z
let's put them in order and there's no
reason why it shouldn't be in that order
yeah it doesn't take that much to work
out um actually let's do it let's do it
you do x equals one
stick that into this solve it if you
solve that
uh you will find three solutions and the
three solutions are these triangles the
the funny triangles here if you have x
equals two you get your two right angle
triangles
if x equals three
you get no
new solutions
and if you're looking at bigger numbers
you'll find it's impossible if you look
at these this equation here on the left
hand side x is the smallest number x is
smaller than y it's smaller than z the
left-hand side which is this will be
smaller
than four lots of
z plus z plus z z is the biggest number
out of those three which is 12 z and on
the right hand side x y z it's going to
be bigger than x is bigger than four so
we can say it's bigger than 4
y is bigger than 4 as well so it's
bigger than 4 times 4
times let's have z here because that
will be 16
z
and to solve it we're looking for a
number smaller than 12z
bigger than 16z at the same time which
is impossible which means you can stop
looking
end of proof so there's only a few
things you have to check and you find
all the possibilities so we found five
triangles where the perimeter is the
same as the area which kind of you know
cute right and that and you can see like
the kind of like perfect numbers uh
here's a here's another triangle i
wanted to show you
let's let's draw it out
this has
33 34
and 65
and for that it's a perimeter of if i'm
all correct 132 and an area we have a
formula for that now but i'll tell you
the area 264. so this is a triangle
where the area is double the perimeter
well i can tell you there are 18
of those
and i can tell you if you want your area
to be some multiple of the perimeter
it's always a finite number so it's
always these lovely little finite lists
so if you want to be equal to the
perimeter
we have our list of five if we want it
to be double the perimeter we now have
this list of 18 and same for triple and
times by 4 and so on so i've got some
news even though these triangles have
been studied for thousands of years
we're still learning new things about
them
and we've discovered some new hero
triangles
and so i've printed them out here new
heroes
yeah
yeah they're kind of interesting you can
see the point where my printer ran out
of ink some of these triangles come in
pairs i'll do before i talk about these
special ones
i'll do an example of a pair of
triangles triangles are getting worse
look at those two
they're terrible they're great triangles
these really valid
lovely drawn triangles 21
20 and 29 and we've got a 17 a 28 here
and a 25 and if you look at the
perimeters and areas because that's what
we're doing the perimeter of the first
one
is 70 the area is 210 also that would be
on our list of triple uh the areas
triple the perimeter this one perimeter
of 70 area of 210.
like sometimes when we're studying
numbers numbers come in pairs sometimes
these triangles are coming pairs because
they have the same perimeter same area
different triangles but they they have
this in common so there's infinitely
many of these pairs if you want to go
looking for them but this one is special
and this pair is special and unique
because it is the only pair that has a
right angle triangle and an isosceles
triangle
with the same perimeter same area this
was proven to be the only pair oh in
2018
so really recently even though this
stuff goes back thousands of years
this has only just been shown to be this
unique pair of triangles you can find
these triangles without too much
difficulty but proving that they're the
only
possible pair like this was quite
difficult i said there were no
equilateral hero triangles it's just
impossible um so you've got
nice equilateral triangle
all got the same side i'm afraid your
area is always going to have some sort
of root it's also going to be some
irrational numbers horrible
but there are some near misses
and so there are a few examples of this
but i like this one in particular 13 14
15.
so they're just either side of 14. if
you take 14 as the middle number
one below one above and that not an
equilateral triangle perimeter 42
and an area
of oh
84 which also means it's one of our
double
area on the list
just misses being an equilateral also
there are examples of this that are
bigger
uh where you just it's just the three
consecutive numbers and the bigger it is
the more it looks like an extra
electoral triangle as well
we've got some superhero triangle
merchandise like t-shirts and cups and
things just because well because it's
good fun it's a good talking point and
also it's a way for you to support
number fire check out the links on
screen and down in the description
thanks for watching we'll be back again
soon
this is true as well
if the circle happens to overlap we
definitely still get a circle this point
if this is a
this will involve in virtual point there
is touching this circle